I started out as a Sorcerer's Apprentice
and I worked my
way up to being a mad scientist and
these are a few of the steps along the
way what I learned doing that first that
you have to work the waves now we could
spend the whole sim seminar just talking
about tech waves and all of the aspects
of them yeah you can't ignore them never
stop they keep coming it can't be too
early it can't be too late so a surfer
actually can choose which wave but in
tech we can't if we if you miss a wave
you can wipeout second thing I learned
is you have to own your IP you have to
own your intellectual property and we
can talk about all the reasons for that
I did one thing where I worked for a
company that Bank of America that didn't
know how to file a patent and somebody
stole the technology but that wasn't the
worst thing they implemented it and they
implemented it badly and so they
convinced the world that it wouldn't
work so the really bad things can happen
if you don't own your IP so I'm going to
give you a few examples of people not
owning their IP when I was in my early
teens this is the late 1950s my family
had a family friend who was a optics
engineer and he asked me if I would help
him become a lab assistant in his optics
lab in his basement at home and I said
sure well it turned out I had two jobs
the first was never looked down the
throat of the laser and the second was
to keep him company and every once in a
while hand him a screwdriver he told me
that he had invented the gaseous planar
laser which was the first form of lasers
but he didn't think they were important
and he hadn't bothered to patent it and
so he was scrambling to try to catch up
there's a famous story about Western
Union Western Union was the first
electronic communications really
large-scale electronic communications
network in the United States Alexander
Graham Bell went to Western Union and
said I'd like to sell you the patent on
the telephone
Western Union said well we don't think
anybody wants to talk all these
businesspeople want a written record and
now there's no value in the telephone
patent no thank you we don't want the
patent they continued that process of
not paying attention to the technology
waves and not doing anything to capture
intellectual property and when the ASCII
dial-up modem came along Western Union
as a communications company dried up and
blew away IBM missed a wave and they've
been shrinking but they have been very
careful to develop and maintain a strong
and growing patent portfolio so the
jury's out we don't know in the long
term whether they'll survive but they
have a better chance now it's just not
me that's been a Sorcerer's Apprentice
and II kind of gave a little
introduction and some examples first I
should talk about Qualcomm Qualcomm
actually did do both of those things and
one of the examples is Qualcomm built a
patent portfolio based on CDMA and
that's how they founded the company but
they saw that the technology wave was
coming and that OFDM was going to
replace CDMA and this was long before it
actually happened they saw it coming
they went out and bought a small
technology company that had a OFDM
patent portfolio and they brought that
portfolio in they had the people in that
small company train their CDMA engineers
and how to design OFDM systems and focus
on building and growing that patent
and without that Qualcomm wouldn't be
here today they successfully managed
both the wave and the intellectual
property now I said I was a Sorcerer's
Apprentice do you remember the story
about The Sorcerer's Apprentice The
Sorcerer's Apprentice is given the job
of cleaning up the lab and decides to
use the technology which is spells and
every time it happens to be a male every
time he does it he either creates
another problem or another set of
opportunities and then he has to do
another and another and it keeps going
and he has layers upon layers upon
layers of spells well the same thing has
happened in our large-scale systems and
Andy made a distinction between
networking and computing in my view
there is no distinction we do not have a
large-scale system that does not have
both communications and computing and
there are people who look at the inside
of a microprocessor and say it's all
communications it's not computing anyway
so you can rather than have an argument
about which is which let's just say that
networks includes both so we had these
large-scale systems and there's layers
upon layers upon layers of historical
technology in the financial services
industry we have code that and it's not
compatible and we we run old operating
systems because we have code that was
written in assembly language 50 or 60
years ago that nobody knows how it works
nobody there's no documentation and the
operation is don't touch it leave it
alone cross your fingers we'll just hope
that it works and it's it's kind of like
magic we'd really don't know what's
there and you know your financial
transactions rely on that so we have
these layers of technology but then we
also have vendors who want to
differentiate their products and so that
we have these proprietary systems so we
have layers of proprietary systems
layers of technology
and then we have to combine things to
make the function that we want and if
you look at our systems our large-scale
systems they look like colonies of
single-cell animals each little
subsystem works very well within its own
little subsystem but when it's trying to
be combined with other subsystems you
know kind of maybe they work but they
require a lot of manual intervention too
to keep them running and they're not
flexible they're brittle they break they
they crash and they're not efficient and
they're expensive to operate so what can
we do about that
well biology face the same problem we
look at the evolution of life on the
planet we went through a stage of
evolution where the the the most complex
forms were colonies of single-cell
animals and they worked much better than
a single-cell animal but they didn't
work very efficiently they had all of
the same problems they were brittle
brittle that were unreliable and they
were inefficient and and they couldn't
protect themselves they had security
problems too and so what did what did
biology do about this biology developed
and over to overlays one is the nervous
system and the other is the immune
system and then the nervous system is
based on this idea of distributed
intelligence we call them ganglion so
I'm standing here right now and in my
toes right down in my feet their
ganglion and they're receiving signals
from sensors and they're sending signals
to the muscles to keep me from falling
over I've got them in my legs etc if all
those signals had to go from my toes to
my brain and back to my toes again I'd
be lying on the ground before they got
there
so the the idea of ganglion and
distributed intelligence is important of
course there's a central intelligence -
we've got the brain and then the immune
system so we have skin and the skin is
designed to keep bad stuff out and it
keeps 90 some percent 98 whatever you
want to say 99 97 96 but there's so much
bad stuff flying around that every that
we know that bad stuff is going to get
in and so the immune system is designed
to find it and take care of it when that
happens and it also has a distributed
functionality lymph nodes so if you
think about how could we build systems
how could we use what we learn from
nature to make our systems operate like
a single multi cell animal so and why do
we want to do this now why when of this
is what's going on now that makes this
so critically important well you know a
financial transactions are important
making sure that accounting systems work
is important but if something goes wrong
you can take some time to fix it if you
if you're driving an autonomous vehicle
maybe you don't have time to fix
something if it goes wrong if you if
your whole house is being run by you
know some combination of smart systems
it could be deadly if things go wrong so
as we go through this software is Asian
this wave of software now running so
much of our lives the systems that
support it are critical and we cannot be
so laissez-faire about them they have to
be reliable and the other thing is of
course
if they're going to be as widely
deployed as we want them to be and if
we're going to have a reasonable
standard of living for people on the
planet the costs of operating them have
to be manageable and this is happening
in the context of a fundamental change
in cybercrime so we have you know we
started out with kids in the basement
having fun trying to break into systems
now we have organized crime and there's
lots of different ways some people say
organized crime doing cyberattacks
generates more money than the entire
illegal drug trade on the planet other
people say it's the largest industry by
dollar volume on the planet pick your
numbers it's big and nation states
decided that was too much a fun game
and so now we have nation state actors
and then we have just like we had the
pirates in England and France and Spain
back in the 1500s and 1600s
we have nation state-sponsored hacking
organizations so we have various
sophisticated attackers so I'm going to
talk today about material covered by a
patent portfolio it's the portions of
the portfolio that I can talk about are
the portions where the patents have been
granted and where or where they have
been published patent authorities
typically at a certain point and they
have different rules about how and when
to do this publish a patent application
while it's under active consideration
and at that either point granting or
publishing the information is open to
the public and therefore I can
talk about it this is so what we'll
discuss today is approximately half of
the portfolio so here is an example of
that kind of Cluj I was talking about
this picture is was developed by 3gpp it
is the architecture for 4G now there's a
little box over in the left hand side
labeled Yui that's user equipment in a
large network there is a hundred million
of those pieces of user equipment there
is some place between a hundred and two
hundred of these large cellular networks
on the planet there's another little box
there labeled a node B II node B is a
fancy name for a base station in a
hundred million subscriber cellular
network
there's a million base stations every
one of the lines on this picture is a
simple line but it isn't really a line
there is a whole communications network
underneath that so there's routers and
switches there's it could be plain old
telephone system twisted pair it could
be t1 t2 t3 t4 t5 it could be coax could
be fiber-optic could be microwave think
about every form of communications and
computing technology that's existed in
the last sixty years it's in those
little lines and this isn't everything
so on top of this there's a system
called OSS operating support system
which has several dozen subsystems and
there's another system on top of all of
that called customer support system
which has a whole bunch of subsystems
so this is an example of one of these
large complicated networks now just to
make it a little more messy this is 4G
today in most of every everyone that I
know of who runs a really large net well
no I shouldn't say there's a few in
developing countries where this is not
true but every large network in a
developed country runs 2g 3G and 4G so
there's three versions of this three
different versions non compatible
versions running on top of each other
embedded in this whole thing so how do
we make this operate like a single multi
cell animal so the we had the first
thing is we have to overlay a nervous
system on it here is a nervous system
they've has two components orchestrators
there's an Orchestrator associate
associated with each subsystem
within the span of control of this
system it is the primary mechanism by
which operation staff NOC is network
operation center talks and controls it
is the mechanism by which data is
exported to other systems or imported
from other systems we'll talk about what
what the orchestrators do and how
they're set up in a minute
the orchestrators are created and the
configuration is managed by the
conductor and that the conductor can
have some global functions but its
primary function is to create and
configure the orchestrators the
orchestrators operate based upon
objectives algorithms and constraints
each one has their own set of objectives
algorithms and constraints and they
interact with their neighbors using this
process of
objectives algorithms and constraints
now in order to do that they all have to
speak the same language they has to have
every one of the subsystems has a
different data model and has different
sets of interfaces so we have to create
a meta model we have to translate all of
those underlying models into a
consistent model that we can work with
across the whole system but we can't not
a priori define what that mam metal
model is and it won't hold still because
every time we add a new type of device
and new technology a vendor does a
software upgrade they're going to add
and subtract data elements so we have to
be able to make this meta model change
and we can't shut the system down to do
maintenance you know when you have
Mexican food and then the next meal is
Chinese food you don't shut your body
down to do database maintenance you have
a way of dynamically reconfiguring
yourself to take advantage of the new
environment the system has to be able to
do that also there's this the amount of
data involved in this because all of
these different little systems are just
constantly there's all kinds of log
files there's all kinds of operational
data and if you try to collect all that
data and you try to collect it in a
central site you end up with too much
data and it's too old by the time it
gets to the central site it's no longer
you know relevant so instead of doing
that you want the system to deliver just
the data that's needed just where it's
needed just when it's needed so those
are the kind of be though and then
there's this the process by which the
orchestrators work together there has to
be an old brain process and there has to
be a new brain process
the the old brain process is the reflex
process and so there are certain things
where you know if something happen
happens you have to do B so you you want
to be able to implement those kinds of
reflex processes and you'd like them to
be able to operate across multiple
orchestrators so when I hit your knee
right under your kneecap there's a
sensor think about an Orchestrator
attached to that sensor and then there's
an Orchestrator attached to your muscle
that causes your your leg to go up
that's a reflex well so we could have
similar kinds of things happen here but
there's going to be things that we where
we don't know what's going to happen and
we don't know exactly what the right
thing to do is a priori and so that's
got to have a new praying process by
which we can analyze the environment and
and and make make decisions that are
right for that particular circumstance
so that's what the process means now
we've implemented this this is a a
demonstration of a macro cell system I
didn't talk about the fact when I showed
you that spaghetti diagram there's a
million macro cells there can be right
now like 250,000 small cells when 5 G's
deployed there could be 5 million small
cells but anyway this is macro cells
typically oh by the way it it costs a
network operator like Verizon 10 times
as much as the equipment cost just to
install and provision in other words to
install and configure that a base
station in the field and it can take
months and so what we see here on the
top layer we have this OSS I didn't tell
you there's I said OSS and customer
support system there's also a business
support system I mean when I there's
systems upon systems upon systems and
they all have little bits and pieces
that we got to here an inventory
management system and a configuration
management system and thereby different
vendors and they were incompatible and
how do they get tied together today by
human beings operators have to take the
output of one and put it into the other
and so and when you're talking about
millions of things you can think about
what that means now in the particular
system that we we did this this was
specified by a group of the largest
cellular operators in the world and we
had juniper providing the
interconnection and then ZTE has two
different divisions in two different
parts of China and they might as well be
speaking different languages and be in
different countries because they don't
design systems the same way they don't
understand each other they don't have
interfaces that work with each other and
oh by the way one product line in in one
of these divisions will not be
compatible with the next product line
because everybody's got a better idea
and things keep constantly changing so
part of what vendors do to try to help
manage this chaos is they build what are
called element management systems so
here's another layer that wasn't in the
spaghetti diagram so ZTE has an element
management system for all of the core
components and another element
management system for all the base
stations and you can imagine if network
operator has three or four vendors
there's going to be six seven 12 a dozen
of these in every data center and there
could be three six twelve pick your
number of Bay of data centers in China
there's one in every province so it
could be like 52 and when you the the
use case here was to have an existing
network with two macro base stations and
you want to add capacity so you put a
third base station in when you put a
third base station in you have to
install that base station you have to
provision it but you have to reconfigure
the other two base stations so that they
all don't interfere with each other and
the base station that you install you
also have to configure though all of the
communications links between it and the
EPC which is the Evolved Packet core and
and all of the subsystems within the
pack Evolved Packet core here we show
the security gateway the sgw and the Mme
the mobility management entity but
there's others in there too and in this
whole process can take months and and
and it can cost because we're talking
about it ten times the cost just to go
out in the field and install the base
station it could be another ten times
that in planning and in organizing and
getting all of this to work together and
it's all labor it's all paying people to
turn the crank
so we automated that whole thing and we
were able to do the provisioning and
reconfiguration in less than a second
and to do it without human operators
okay so we did another demo and this is
with small cells and and this is
interesting because it shows more of the
the internals of the system so um stands
for umbrella model that's what we call
the metamodel
and there is in every Orchestrator
there's a bridge function and the bridge
function translates between the
interface and the end the data model of
the system it's associated with into the
metamodel and each of the orchestrators
has all the data about the the subsystem
its associated with but it also has and
it automatically gets all the data that
it needs and it gets it when it needs it
from the neighbors so it does not have
the whole umbrella model it only has a
piece of the ability
but that's all it needs and we instead
of talking about applications we talk
about use cases and the reason we talk
about use cases is because they span
multiple orchestrators and we actually
did this with real equipment again so
with the names of the vendors and stuff
is there now the use cases that we did
with this the first was automated
provisioning and what we found is that
automated provisioning reduces the
installation cost by 50% so to install a
base station just the guys in the field
to do it costs $100,000 when we do this
we reduce the cost of 50,000 because
they can do twice as many base stations
in the same amount of time but then the
the more interesting case is what
happens when something goes wrong and
the thing that goes wrong most typically
is what's called impaired backhaul so
this if 4G standard has a mechanism for
load sharing between base stations in a
neighborhood and but it only knows about
spectrum it only knows about the RF
space so when a new ue when a new device
shows up and says I need service this
mechanism has a way to decide which of
the base stations that device because
typically you can see three or four base
stations which base station you should
assign that device to and it says okay
well who has the most unused RF capacity
and it assigns that UE to that device
but if that base station has lost half
of its backhaul every everybody assigned
to that base station is going to have
lousy quality of service and what
happens is that's what you and I say oh
we got a bad we got a bad line hang up
I'll call you back so everybody's
hanging up and calling back which wipes
out the other base stations in the
neighborhood
and that goes on until somebody and it's
a human being again in an operation
center figures out that there's a
problem and then they have to dispatch a
truck you know there's a truck roll and
so it can go on for a long time it can
go on for months so if if we have and we
have an orchestration system where we
know because we have an Orchestrator
that looks at the backhaul we know when
there's a backhaul problem so if we can
change the allocation of RF capacity
such that the base station with impaired
backhaul has RF capacity that matches
its backhaul capacity and we give the
rest of the backhaul kepada the best of
the RF capacity to the other base
stations that would it's not perfect you
know we still can do better after we fix
things but while we're fixing things the
whole system will run much much much
better so that was the second use case
the problem is okay so first we have to
talk about how often this happens in a
network of a million macro base stations
at any given moment in time there are
10,000 base stations that have been
paired back off ok so just think about
the manual process what seems simple to
do once when you're talking about 10,000
becomes a bigger problem so we don't
know what the situation is with the
neighboring base stations and we don't
know what the right answer is so what we
do is the orchestrator associated with
the backhaul let's the orchestrator
associated with the impaired base
station know that it's backhaul has been
impaired that Orchestrator
then starts a process with the
orchestrators of the other base stations
in the neighborhood it says
hey I need to get rid of capacity now
capacity and 4G and 3G and 5 G's all
measured differently we're just to make
it simple we're going to talk about
channels so I need to give up a channel
can anybody take a channel and then
there's a negotiation procedure and one
of the one of the bidders says ok you
can I want it so you can have it and
then the the orchestrator goes back and
says ok does my backhaul capacity match
my RF capacity no so it goes through the
process again of saying can anybody take
a channel and the negotiation process
goes on again ok so when this goes until
everything gets balanced when the
backhaul is repaired
can you just replay what you've done and
just undo it no you can't and the reason
you can't is because the situation could
have changed one of the other base
stations could have had impaired
backhaul it could have been giving up
capacity a base station can be in more
than one neighborhood it can be passing
capacity to another neighborhood you
don't know what the situation is so you
have to start all over again again with
negotiation so the base station that now
has enough backhaul capacity its
Orchestrator says can anybody give me a
channel and there's a negotiation
process and then through that process we
get back to balance ok so before we get
started can you offer full of comments
about the environment where we're
running I'm running this demonstration
on a Linux laptop with five separate KVM
virtual machines running on board and
I've got three windows on the right side
of your screen which show the console
logs of three of the local distributed
orchestrators for the 3e node B's which
allows you to see a little bit of the
message traffic and the work that's
going on on each of those nodes during
the provisioning process on the left
side of screen is
console which was developed specifically
for this demonstration and the topic of
map view which shows the devices that
are being managed which I can also show
in it topology view and what we'll be
doing is configuring the EBC and then
the three email B's which are associated
with that EPC in this environment and
I'll be doing that by utilizing these
control buttons on the left side of my
screen when I do that I'm gonna go ahead
and start by configuring the EPC what's
going on on the background is that I'm
sending a message to its local
distributed Orchestrator which says
change your state from defined to
configured and when it does so it knows
how to generate this message which is
displayed in this text view in our
umbrella model it generates this and
hands it over to the bridge process
running on that same device which
translates this into a series of calls
that are made to the exposed API on that
device to effect that configuration and
as you see in our display it changed
from yellow to green when that
configuration was complete which took
basically less than a second I'm gonna
go ahead and configure the rest of the
devices now the EPC is up and running
and when I do so you'll see that the
same process takes place the ghrelin
model configuration is generated the
bridge process takes over configures the
device and now everything's green now in
this demo as was explained we're using
this notion from abstract channels which
represents capacity on each of the you
know DS and underneath the configuration
box you'll see a list of channels which
shows the initial capacity allocated to
those devices in the use case where we
had an impairment of a backhaul
basically what we need to do is
the you know the work the orchestrator
that's controlling that you know to be
reallocate some of its capacity to the
other nodes that are operating in the
neighborhood so I'm gonna go ahead and
click on the pair button for you know B
- at which point in time the negotiation
process is started and that local
distributed Orchestrator starts to offer
some of its capacity to its neighbors
and you will see the channels being
reallocated to you know B 1 and e node B
3 men ssin at this point in time that
I've built in a delay in this
negotiation process just to allow you to
see what's going on there's actually 2
second delay in there between iterations
of the reallocation process and that
allows you to to see the channels move
from one device to the other at some
point in time when the backhaul is
impaired or repaired I can restore that
devices capacity by clicking on my
restore button here in which case the
local distributor Orchestrator starts
asking for some of that capacity to be
returned by its neighbors and you can
see everything rebalances and each of
the nodes is running again with 10
channels ok so that was kind of a
discussion and showing you how a system
in a cellular network would work the
same thing can be done in an enterprise
network a government Network everything
is the same except the names of the
devices in the little blue boxes on the
bottom they they change because it's
different subsystems but the same
problems exist and the same solution
works
now what about security so what we want
to be able to do is to find those things
that get through the external barriers
our access control and firewalls and
things like that and then of course we
would like to fix them so we again it's
the same system everything's the same
except the names of the things in the
blue boxes change we're going to talk a
little bit about how this works
so the primary mechanism used to figure
out if something bad has gotten into the
system it's what's called behavioral
analysis behavioral analysis was
developed at Stanford Research Institute
in the late 1980s I actually had a
chance to work with it
in the in that time and it was
originally focused on what's called
intrusion and so the first systems were
called intrusion detection systems or
IDs but it's all the same but I'll give
you kind of an explanation of how it
started so the idea was to figure out if
somebody had stolen somebody else's
credentials and was using them to get
into the system to do bad things
so user profiles were developed so Joe
shows up in Menlo Park every Monday
morning at you know Monday through
Friday logs on at 9:15 logs off at 4:45
all of a sudden
Joe appears to be showing up on Saturday
afternoon from Shenzhen is that Joe was
a it's a behavioral anomaly so then you
have to do an investigation but the
thing is to capture the fact that it's a
behavioral anomaly and so that's what
the behavioral analysis systems did they
would develop a behavior pattern for
each user and then they would alert when
the behavior didn't follow the pattern
now that was expanded to include devices
and anything that has behavior can you
you can develop this kind of behavioral
analysis system for and right now
typically the way these things are done
there's a collector in this case it's
called a security probe there's a
collector out in the field and the
collector collects data though there's
lots of different ways of doing this the
two most typical are that a collector
takes log files from the system's it's
connected to and another way is to
capture all of the IP addresses that
flow through a system and and because
they bring all this data back to a
central site they some of these systems
are already getting close to Ekta bytes
of data and they have to throw it over
they have they don't have storage
systems big enough they have to throw it
away after a few days or a week and it
can take days to find a pattern because
there's so much data you have to wade
through so that they they try to pick
points in the system where they might
get the most leverage and it's quite
typical to to pick a router or a switch
as a place to begin to examine behavior
not only of that switch but everything
of downstream from it and then if
there's an alert if there's a behavioral
change then it it goes to a human
operator and now it's called an SOC a
security operations center and that
operator then has to decide if they want
to take action and if they want to take
action what they should do this turns
out not to be an easy job
it's a it's it turns out that it is
financially almost unaffordable to have
on staff 24/7 people who know the
intimate technical details of every
subsystem in your network every computer
every application every switch every
router every firewall every access
control system etc and even if you have
the money you can't find enough trained
people to do that so what happens is
that people create what are called
playbooks and it's like a recipe if a
happens open this book up and follow the
instructions
the problem with playbooks is that the
people who actually sitting at the
keyboard executing them have no idea
what they're doing and if they hit a
wrong key that finger problem they don't
know how they don't know how to recover
and so we've seen fat finger problems
bring down an entire network s2 went
down for the better part of the day
because of one fat finger problem so
what happens is that the security staff
scratches their head and they say hmm
what's the risk that if we actually do
remediation we're going to crash the
network and that in more often than not
they decide not to fix the problem
because they're afraid that the cure is
worse in the cold so one organization
one u.s. corporation has 300
subsidiaries each subsidiary has a
firewall at least one sometimes two or
three they have one of every firewall
that's ever been manufactured ever been
sold into the market they have firewalls
that are no longer supported by their
vendors that are still running they got
an alert that an attack was coming and
they knew what the IP addresses were
that it was coming from so they could
have gone out to all of the firewalls
and blocked that IP edge
not let anything in from it but they
decided that if they did that the risk
of blowing up the network was so great
that they'd rather let the attack come
and try to clean up the cleanup
afterwards than to prevent it and this
is not an unusual circumstance this is
how and then what happens of course is
these staffs they come to the conclusion
well geez if nobody knows we've been
breached everything's fine so we'll just
keep it a secret and that's what
happened with Yahoo and it only cost
them 1.2 billion dollars when that
because nobody can ever keep those
things secret forever let alone the fact
that the attackers know that they've
done it so you know you're subject to
blackmail so anyway this is the kind of
current situation so we add
orchestrators we add an Orchestrator to
the Behavioral Analysis engine we add an
Orchestrator to the SOC now the reason
we do that is because depending on the
policy just decisions of the
organization they may not want automated
remediation to happen without human
intervention so this allows an alert to
come to the SOC staff and then the SOC
staff to be presented with here's an
analysis of the problem here's what we
recommend you do and guess what they
only have one button to choose they get
to click on yes or no minimize the fat
finger problems ok and but it could also
be automated and then we have a an
Orchestrator associated in this case
with a switch and a router and and we
can see the behavior of the switch in
the router and of the downstream devices
and because we have the capability of
doing this we can actually implement the
remediation actions so here
is an example again this is from the
cellular industry but it applies you can
imagine how this applies in in this use
case we have several small cellular base
stations that are installed in Starbucks
in downtown San Francisco and there is a
virtual EPC a controller that controls
how those base stations talk to the
cellular network and in this use case
one of those base stations becomes
compromised at its stealing customer
information and that is detected by a
behavioral analysis system which sends
out an alert that alert can either be
picked up directly by orchestral
networks local security engines and
acted on directly using rules or that
alert can be presented to a console
operator and that console operator can
take action to quarantine the device so
I'm going to assume that it is the
latter and that we had the console
operators see the alert and is going to
quarantine this first device and as that
happened you may have seen some X line
by on the right hand side and these are
basically just console windows connected
up to our engines so that we can see the
message traffic and you will also have
seen that this window right next to the
device got cleared and the configuration
was removed at this point in time the
device can be analyzed we can figure out
what went wrong how it got compromised
make corrections within our system to
the system configuration and then push
out a new configuration to that device
and bring it back up online
okay there's many different forms of
remediation and during the question and
answer period we can talk about those if
you have questions about them but we can
make this system better so instead of
having a separate collector we can have
the orchestrator also do the collection
and deliver data to the central site
behavioral analysis system but we can
also have the local Orchestrator do its
own behavioral analysis and we can do
this with an extremely small footprint
we don't have to keep all the data so
part of the problem in in the central
site system is that the central site
system has to keep all this data and
it's a huge big bucket of data and then
it has to wander around in that to find
anything but it also has to have a lot
of human people telling it what to look
for it's not you know this is not the
idea of finding patterns with neural
networks people try to say that but it
and security kind of things it doesn't
quite happen that way and we don't want
the orchestrator to be this big huge
thing we want it to be really small and
we'll see how small we want it to be
soon so we have another mechanism and
the way we do this is we create
histograms and we create histograms
without any understanding of what the
parameters mean we don't really care
what the parameters mean all we do is we
take a statistically valid sample and we
create a moving sum average so we
constantly update and we don't keep the
data we just keep the histogram and it's
just one histogram and it's just updated
and it's constantly kind of going
through whatever small change and if
there's a big change then there's an
alert that's a behavior change and
with that we can deploy this out to the
edges of the network and we can still
run the central site system to UM we
could do either or there's another thing
here we have some threat intelligence
systems so that that that u.s.
corporation I told you about that had
300 subsidiaries they scry subscribe to
156 threat intelligence systems so those
each one has a different interface some
send email some are push websites some
or pull websites some are paper they all
have different you know some send out
stuff every minute some sends out stuff
and every hours from every day some
every week some every month etc they're
in that corporation there's one person
and it's not his only job happens to be
a man it's not his only job he has to
run the whole security operation who
reads a hundred and fifty six threat
intelligence reports a day and decides
what if anything to do about them so
again you can imagine what that means in
terms of time and and effectiveness so
we we put an Orchestrator out there and
with orchestrators we we were able to
actually make that threat intelligence
information actionable now in an
enterprise typically enterprises also
have layers of history you know because
of mergers and acquisitions and
reorganizations so they don't have one
of anything and in their security and
their security environments they have
lots of firewalls lots of access control
systems
lots of behavioral analysis systems lots
of element management systems of course
lots of routers and switches and lots of
clouds and lots of there's something up
there called a sim
which is supposed to kind of try to keep
track of things but they have lots of
different versions of those and how is
that all held together again it's either
not held together or it's held together
with manual effort which is expensive
and slow and and scale not effective so
we replace it by putting or enhance it
we don't replace the operators we
enhance the operators by deploying
orchestrators for each of the systems
now what about a cloud well typically
today cloud systems have a behavioral
analysis engine and they have a data
collector but typically the collector is
collecting data on the cloud as a whole
and when you do that what happens to an
individual application can be lost in
the detail in the you know in this flood
of information and the other problem is
that those applications are moving and
what happens if it the application moves
from a internal private cloud to an
external public cloud where you the
organization that is running the
application do not have a behavioral
analysis engine or and you don't have
access to the third-party providers
behavioral analysis engine and maybe
it's not compatible with yours so the
answer is we put an Orchestrator we
associate an Orchestrator with the app
and then the orchestrator moves with the
app the orchestrator then can-can has a
behavior pattern that's unique to the
app and it can see when the app is
deviating from its normal behavior and
it can see that regardless of where the
app is running at that any given moment
well how about vehicles well we have a
car shown here but it could be a it
could be a boat it could be an airplane
it could be a drone any kind of vehicle
but let's talk about cars as an example
so cars today have a component called a
telecommunications control unit TCU and
that TCU handles all of the electronic
communications to the outside world oh
by the way do you know that there are
more cars stolen in the United States
today by hacking to the control system
than there are by physically breaking
into the car yeah
just interesting kind of to see how the
world's changing crime you know
criminals are pretty good at being
dynamic our systems are not as good as
being dynamic and that's why we need to
have this kind of capability okay so we
could put an Orchestrator just on the
telecommunications control unit and we
could observe the behavior of the TCU
and we could observe the behavior of
everything downstream but of course in
doing that there's some latency issues
because whatever's happening downstream
it's going to take maybe a second for us
to find out about it do I care about a
second well howdy is slang a version of
the a8 which has an autonomous driving
capability the capability is such that
it will be engaged if and only if the
vehicle and the traffic around it is
going at 30 miles an hour or less and
it's on a divided highway if either one
of those conditions are not true it
doesn't change lanes it just stops and
it turns on its flashers unless the
human operator takes control
now when outtie sells the vehicle they
sign a
contract in which they say they are
responsible financially responsible for
all accidents that happen when that
vehicle is an autonomous mode do you
think Odie is willing to let something
go wrong with inside the car and let it
go on for a second or two before they
find out about it okay so inside the car
are a whole bunch of other control units
there can be as many as fifty of these
control units I just made up some
examples an engine control unit a
steering control unit a braking control
unit you can decide where you want to
how you want to associate orchestrators
with the control units you can go down
as far into detail as you want these are
remember they're very small they have an
extremely small footprint and now we
have another entity fleet fleet
operations so in the Audi example I buy
I'm an individual consumer I buy an Audi
a8 but from a security point of view
outtie is still the fleet manager
they're going to keep track of that car
to make sure that they don't end up with
financial responsibility for an accident
they could prevent okay so now we have
these two systems we have the nervous
system the ganglion and we have the
immune system the lymph nodes what
happens if we combine them well there's
some things that we can do that we
couldn't do before so for example right
now if I'm a cellular network operator I
have to decide where to put my base
stations and that's why I may spend six
months going through an analysis before
I put a base station out there it's a
big expense and I have to hope that I
get that I get enough base stations
where the traffic is because otherwise
bad quality of service and my customers
go away I want to make sure I don't have
too many base stations where there's no
traffic
because it's too expensive so I'm
constantly trying to figure out how to
do this well what would happen if we put
the base stations in a vehicle and the
vehicle went where there was a demand
for service well they can't do that
today because it takes them pick your
time week month whatever to reconfigure
the neighborhood when you add another
base station but we can do it in less
than a second so as that as the vehicles
move around and the we can reconfigure
the cells so that the sole thing becomes
dynamic tremendous improvement is in
efficiency and then the question is well
what about the security not only of the
vehicles now we've got a base station in
the vehicle but how about the users
inside the vehicle and by users of mean
uese right user equipment can be that we
really don't care what it is so we can
provide kind of a sone of security so
that there's security inside the vehicle
and we can make it at the same time
become a base station that moves to
where there's a need for the base
station ok so everything we've talked
about up until now has been about big
systems but if you look at what's going
on inside single semiconductors single
chips it looks pretty much like a big
system it's we we've got SOC s now that
a network tying all of these separate
little cores together and typical size
of an SOC today is 30
course people in the industry are
talking about 300 course people in
academia are talking about 3,000 course
now there typically is a component
inside the SOC that's responsible for
external communication off-chip
communication it doesn't have a standard
name like TCU but so we just talked
about are there and we could look
downstream at everything going on inside
the chip and we can do this because we
have this the orchestrator has such a is
such a small thing now to do this we can
argue about software versus hardware it
doesn't matter it's complicated to talk
about how to do the software solution
but adding a very very small component
inside that ship is there's plenty of
room we're we've gotten feature sizes so
small now that people are trying to
figure out what to do with all the real
estate and and chips now our pad limited
the number of external connections
determines the size of the chip and so
how do you make good use of the
real-estate so so there's room in here
to put orchestrators we could put the
orchestrators associate them with
individual SOC course to make sure that
the core is behaving correctly now in
the last year or two we've had this
whole set of concerns come up about
called well the friend of mine and he's
corrupted me he calls it smelter down
but that has to do with in chip in
processor vulnerabilities John Hennessy
gave a talk a few months ago here at EE
380 and he said two interesting things
first thing he said was there's a new
one of these vulnerabilities
discovered every month second thing he
said was he John Hennessy could in the
process of designing a processor put a
backdoor into the processor that you
would never find and he guaranteed he
could do that and I believed him and I
don't think he's the only one who can do
that and there's some indication that
that's been done and there's some
tension going on between governments and
vendors which you guys can all fill in
the blanks okay so can we predict all of
the vulnerabilities no we cannot can we
close all the vulnerabilities well in
smelter down the answer was yes we could
close all the vulnerabilities if we went
back to 1990 performance and everybody
said no don't take us back to 1990 so
how do we keep performance and have
security now how important is this in
processor vulnerability well to use it
it takes a sophisticated attacker do we
have sophisticated attackers we have
nation states we have pirate groups we
have organized crime are they
sophisticated enough yes what is the
consequence of having these
vulnerabilities
I'd really don't want to go into it in a
public setting but it is possible using
these vulnerabilities to exfiltrate data
from any application running in any
public cloud anywhere in the world today
and it's not hard for a sophisticated
person so it's a serious serious serious
problem so how can we solve it well if
we put orchestrators in the key places
and and it has to do with where how data
moves inside the chip inside the
processor we can and they have
orchestrators have to be very small but
we can make them very small remember
we're not storing a lot of data we just
have this histogram and we really don't
even have to know what what that
a piece of the puzzle is doing all we
have to do is be able to establish what
it's normal behavior is then we can tell
if somebody has intruded invaded somehow
is exfiltrating data or forcing control
actions which are unauthorized and if we
see them and we can see that that's
happening then we can take remediation
steps so as you've got a feel for this I
didn't really cover everything because
we didn't have time
also it sometimes it's overwhelming to
put everything in one in one fell swoop
but it's a it's a very generalized
solution to these kinds of problems and
these problems exist in smart homes
smart off a smart factory smart highway
there's there's a problem in SOC design
and operation that has to do with
combinations and permutations the a5
there's a joke in the community that the
a5 was called the a5 because it took 5
years to develop that's apples a5 can't
get a I can't get a laugh out of this
audience it's so the technology can be
used there also how do we move you know
each one of the major vendors wants to
lock us in we get an application running
in their cloud in in fact they want we
have a private cloud they want us to buy
their cloud software to run their cloud
software in our in our data center so
that we can move from our data center to
their public cloud and back and forth
they want to lock us in so ok in
combinations of information from
incompatible systems if you know about
health record systems in San Diego in
San Diego County
there's the Army Air Force
mavey each one has a separate medical
system there's the Veterans Affairs each
one has a separate medical system
there's the county medical system
there's the University of San Diego
Medical Center they have a separate
system and then there's all the private
practitioners and they all have separate
systems and they're all incompatible and
one person or one family could actually
see every one of those in one day so how
do you you know that's like when you go
to the doctor and the doctor says are
you sick
and you say well I came here to find out
and they say well but we don't have the
records tell us you know so we become
the walkin information system it doesn't
work very well
there's also implications for standards
instead of trying to specify everything
leaving stuff up to negotiation there's
an article here that's been published in
December you can look at if you're
interested this the technology is
agnostic it covered it it doesn't matter
what the underlying technology is these
are the granted patents and the in
process published patents that cover
stuff we talked about today and in
conclusion so it's why because it's time
why is it time because of the reliance
we have is society and the increasing
reliance for life on these systems how
do we make them we got to make them work
better how do we do that we make them
work like instead of colonies of
single-cell animals a single multi cell
animal to make sure that it gets done
right we need to make sure that we have
control of the intellectual property
okay if Andi will allow me well I'll be
happy to take questions
thank you